bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de municipal 2014 rendez-vous
politique de la rédaction qui dorénavant
vous est proposé chaque semaine en
direct à 18h30 et ce jusqu'à la fin du
mois de mars alors des invités en
plateau ce soir tout d'abord Michel
chapeau bonsoir vous êtes candidats je
vous le dis d'une liste de rassemblement
c'est comme ça que vous présentez votre
liste à Maurepas vous êtes soutenu
notamment par le modèle et puis Gaëtan
Desjardins concernant municipal
d'opposition à Saint-Cyr-l'École qui
nous rejoindra en deuxième partie des
missions on va donc commencer par partir
du côté de Maurepas avec vous Michel
Chapat vous avez été adoublé on peut
dire ça comme ça par Georges Mougeot le
maire sortant qui a choisi de ne pas se
représenter vous êtes à ses côtés depuis
1989 vous êtes adjoint au finances et
j'ai envie de dire que le départ de
Georges moujo à Maurepas attise beaucoup
les appétits parce qu'il y a pas mal de
candidats déjà déclarés comme Michel hey
adjoint au sport sans étiquette j'ai
enceinte de forêt qu'on s'est municipale
d'opposition il se met la vanne investit
par partie socialiste et puis à droite
il y a Pierre Le personnel udi et
grégorygaresti UMP qui sont tous les
deux sommets par leur direction
départementale respectives de faire
l'Alliance et puis n'agit de base pour
Debout la République
et le fond de vous avoir
encore une liste supplémentaire à
Maurepas ça fait quand même beaucoup la
bataille est donc et donc rude vous
l'avez dit je l'ai dit c'est vous vous
présentez en tout cas comme une liste de
de rassemblements vous vous dites je
suis un homme de la gauche modéré vous
avez le soutien du MoDem bon c'est un
peu compliqué comment vous allez la
comment vous allez la définir
des propositions mortasien pour assurer
la continuité de l'action que nous avons
conduite avec Georges Mougeot c'est
extrêmement clair je le dis depuis le
début j'ai souhaité au tout départ de
mon de ma démarche que toutes les
composantes de la majorité municipale
ensemble ben comme vous l'avez dit
certains ont choisi d'y aller séparément
c'est leur problème ce n'est pas ce
n'était pas ma vision initiale donc j'ai
proposé une démarche à certains membres
de gens les non politiques les non
affiliés à parti politique les
indépendants de la majorité qui viennent
entendu sont partis avec moi le modem
sert à lié à ce mouvement et nous avons
dans l'équipe qui est composé d'une
soixantaine de personnes des femmes et
des hommes qui ont des options qui ne
sont pas toujours les mêmes à gauche ou
pas forcément à gauche mais qui sera
semble pour l'intérêt de Maurepas et qui
reconnaissent que l'action conduite avec
Georges mouchaux et particulièrement
positif pour la commune comment c'est
fait la passation
de pouvoir parce que vous n'êtes pas et
lui-même mais comment ça s'est fait avec
Georges mougeois quel moment il a décidé
par exemple de vous dire je ne vais pas
me représenter c'est pas répondre à sa
place si vous avez des questions à lui
poser vous lui posez à lui vous répondra
quand on est son adjoint premier ou
deuxième depuis un certain nombre
d'années et c'est sûr que il y a quand
même des liens de proximité très proche
et qu'on parle on a parlé depuis un
certain temps de cette éventuelle était
là et c'est fait il y a un certain temps
c'est vous qui dites à certains temps
vous n'avez jamais été candidat entre
mon propre
à des élections politiques
est-ce que c'est pas un handicap selon
vous même si depuis 89 vous êtes au côté
de on va pas revenir au débat de la
campagne présidentielle où il y avait le
même type d'arguments non c'était pas
c'est pas du tout puisque les gens
connaissent quand même à mon repas ça
fait quand même 30 ans plus de 30 ans
que j'y habite que je côtoie les
mortaisienne et morpasiens dans les
responsabilités publiques et même si je
ne suis pas numéro un il me connaissent
ils savent ce que j'ai fait au côté de
Georges joujou comment vous allez mener
campagne et comment alors je reviens je
suis obsédé par lui mais enfin c'est le
maire sortant est-ce qu'il va mener
campagne auprès de vous à vos côtés
Georges choisit de faire ce qu'il veut
il choisit une intervenir quand il veut
la difficulté quand on émerge sortant
c'est qu'on est maire de tous les
morpasiens donc on ne peut pas se lancer
dans la campagne électorale trop tôt il
le fera le moment choisi je crois qu'il
a donné quelques éléments samedi dernier
lors de ces vœux aux jeunes et il le
fera le moment choisi mais avant le 23
mars je voudrais vous faire réagir alors
on va partir de l'autre côté du bord
politique pierre de Guérinel première
adjoint il dit ancien premier adjoint
udi et Grégory garesti UMP sont sommet
de se rassembler pour une ni l'Union dès
le premier tour ça vous inquiète
il faudra quand même qu'ils expliquent
au mortalien comment un premier adjoint
pendant 5 ans et demi qui a choisi de de
missionner pour les raisons qui sont les
siennes sur le devant lesquels je n'ai
rien pas de commentaire pour des raisons
strictement positives comment il peut
s'allier avec quelqu'un qui nous tire
dessus depuis le début du mandat qui dit
qu'en germal etc ça c'est leur affaire
c'est leur affaire avec les morts
pasiens d'accord donc vous regardez ça
comme ça l'extérieur
qu'est-ce qu'il voit alors il est très
attentiste et très serein surtout
je vous propose en tout cas d'écouter
Valérie Pécresse la prison de
départementale de l'UMP au sujet de
Maurepas vous allez voir que c'est une
ville qui intéresse
et l'UMP veulent l'Union à Maurepas nous
avons aujourd'hui toutes les
informations qui nous disent que si nous
faisons l'Union Maurepas et gagnable la
succession de Monsieur Mougeot est un
moment historique pour la ville ne
laissons pas mort pas retombées dans les
mains d'un maire de gauche qui ne fait
pas le rassemblement puisque aujourd'hui
vous savez qu'il y a quatre candidats de
gauche à Maurepas ça veut dire que la
ville est profondément divisée ça veut
dire que il n'y a pas de rassembleur à
gauche alors comment vous réagissez il
n'y a pas de rassembleur à
gauchement à droite ça sera une première
chose et effectivement j'aurais souhaité
que certains ne se lancent pas tout seul
dans cette campagne et qu'on en parle or
c'est leur choix c'est pas le mien alors
quand vous parlez de des personnes c'est
qui les ont tous les autres
est-ce que vous avez entamé des contacts
les élections
si vous voulez de notre projet pour mon
repas la solidarité il y a besoin d'être
solidaire il y a besoin d'être
bienveillant les uns vis-à-vis des
autres il n'y a pas besoin de il faut
pas crisper les uns vis-à-vis des autres
il faut une ville absolument tranquille
et paisible et pour avoir une ville
tranquille épaissible il faut assurer la
sécurité qui est le gage de la
tranquillité et aussi la solidarité en
particulier vis-à-vis des plus fragiles
et nous avons une démarche tout à fait
particulière qu'on développera au cours
de cette campagne vis-à-vis des
personnes isolées on n'est pas isolé
seulement quand on est âgé on est isolé
aussi à tout moment de la vie quand un
incident de la vie vous frappe et la
difficulté pour les services sociaux
publics c'est de détecter ces situations
là pour qu'elles ne se dégrade pas et
vous souhaitez la création notamment
d'un office municipal la création d'un
office municipal de la solidarité et
régulièrement des assises sociales pour
la commune un petit mot sur
l'environnement l'environnement nous
avons fait beaucoup oui nous nous fait
beaucoup pour protéger l'environnement
la ville si vous voulez l'aménagement de
la ville comporte trois grandes zones la
zone urbaine habitée la zone urbaine des
activités économiques et la zone urbaine
d'un environnement protégé nous l'avons
entretenu nous continuerons à
l'entretenir y compris à l'intérieur de
la zone
urbaine et nous proposons un certain
nombre d'innovations en particulier une
charte antibruit parce que le bruit
c'est la nuisance numéro 1 dans les
villes et je pense qu'on l'oublie un peu
trop ici et là et deuxièmement une
démarche tout à fait particulière pour
la protection de l'arbre je me signale
que c'est Jacques Chirac qui à Paris
avait initié ce type de politique et que
ça a été oublié depuis ici et là
d'accord je sais pas ça fait un peu
anecdotique comme priorité de campagne
si je peux me permettre
un des éléments dans le cadre de
l'environnement la priorité de
l'environnement c'est aussi d'appliquer
le plan local d'urbanisme que nous
venons de voter d'adopter et qui nous
donnera du travail pendant toutes les
six années à venir et le dernier point
c'est l'innovation avec un effort
particulier qui sera demandé au service
de de la mairie toute une réorganisation
vous allez faire un bouleversement
mérite vous m'avez dit que j'allais
révolutionné non si vous voyez un
révolutionnaire en moi je crois que là
il faut changer de lunettes si je filme
permettre non il faut faire preuve
d'imagination dans tous les actes de
public de la commune qui soit vis-à-vis
de la population ou à l'intérieur des
services les services travaillent
beaucoup travaillent très sérieusement
sont très rigoureux mais il faudra vu
les contraintes que l'État fait peser
sur les communes d'ailleurs parfaitement
injuste je dis au passage je suis pas
tout à fait en phase avec le discours du
président de la République là-dessus
mais il va falloir faire avec et
demander un effort à tout le monde et
d'imagination c'est ce que ça veut dire
voilà on suivra les le programme de
Michel ça pas candidat au municipal à
Maurepas pour sur une liste de larges
rassemblements ça va j'ai beau merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
allez on va poursuivre cette émission
municipale 2014 avec l'accord entre
l'UMP et l'UDI justement pour ces
élections un accord qualifié
d'historique par les deux formations
alors tout semble partiellement acté
sauf dans une commune et on vient d'en
parler Maurepas
historique Valérie Pécresse et Arnaud
Richard responsable UMP et udi dans le
département ont qualifié historique
l'accord signé entre les deux formations
à l'occasion des municipales c'est
quasiment unique en Île-de-France ou
seulement Paris a signé le même accord
pour soutenir des listes umpud sur notre
secteur des candidats auront donc la
double investiture c'est le cas
manileamo et l'encours Saint-Cyr-l'École
Bois-d'Arcy et Voisins-le-Bretonneux ou
la candidate d'Alexandra Rosetti
ancienne premier adjointudi fait les
frais de cet accord dans d'autres
communes c'est un double soutien
qu'obtiennent les candidats comme à
Guyancourt Montigny trappes-la-verrière
ou Les Clayes-sous-Bois l'objectif est
clair pour ces municipales conserver les
bastions et tentaient d'en faire
basculer d'autres comme la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans Yvelines
actuellement socialiste nous avons un
vrai espoir de faire basculer la vie
nouvelle aujourd'hui maintenant pour la
première fois nous présentons une équipe
de 7 candidats on peut même dire 8 en
ajoutant Bois-d'Arcy
si nous avons une liste d'union elle
aura la double investiture udi UMP sinon
il n'y aura pas d'investiture sur
Maurepas je connais assez peu monsieur
garestier j'estime la manière dont il a
comme la dit Valérie tout à l'heure un
dynamisme indéniable avec les militants
et je le comprends ça et ça se respecte
simplement je lui passe un message aussi
ferme que sympathique de lui dire que
l'unité est nécessaire à Maurepas pour
gagner voilà et que sinon nous ne
gagnerons pas cette ville voilà Pierre
Le Guérinel présent lors de ce point
presse à rappeler sa volonté de faire
une liste commune des rencontres doivent
encore avoir lieu cette semaine pour la
droite et le centre l'enjeu d'importance
avec le départ du maire d'hiver gauche
Georges Mougeot la ville selon eux
prenables enfin à Coignières le merump
Henri Payet par sans aucune investiture
il n'a rien demandé à préciser Valérie
Pécresse
allez on poursuit cette émission avec
maintenant on va partir du côté de
Saint-Cyr-l'École alors en 2008 Bernard
de bain et réélu dès le premier tour
avec 50,56% des voix il y avait trois
listes en présence dont celle de Marc
Sadoun pour le Parti socialiste tu sais
de Daniel Farnier sur lequel vous vous
trouviez Gaëtan Desjardins bonsoir
bonsoir et cette fois vous vous avez
fait le choix de vous lancer dans la
campagne en tête de liste vous présenter
une liste que vous avez que vous
souhaitez en tout cas indépendante et
sans étiquette mais je rappelle quand
même que vous avez été premier adjoint
de l'ancien maire Philippe Lavaux de
2001 à 2000 2006 alors avant de vous
expliquer un peu les raisons de votre
candidature je voudrais vous faire
réagir à ce que nous a dit Bernard de
bain sur ce même plateau il y a 15 jours
où il aimerait bien trouver
éventuellement un accord avec vous avant
le premier tour des municipales
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez à
Bernard de Saint-Cyr un petit peu vite
en besogne il faut déjà que le premier
tour est lié et c'est son souhait mais
il ne m'en a jamais parlé je n'ai jamais
eu de contact direct avec lui
effectivement qu'à ce jour je suis très
courtisé mais ça en reste là et on verra
le soir du premier tour alors pourquoi
vous avez fait ce choix de vous
présenter là en tête de liste qu'est-ce
qui ce qui me motive c'est de voir ce
qui se passe depuis 2006 sur cette
commune
ça fait des années qu'il y a des erreurs
qu'il y a des des fautes je vois les
erreurs par exemple on parle du foyer la
roche on avait tout à fait la
possibilité de l'acheter de le rénover
pour garder quelque chose pour nos
anciens le maire a fait le choix de le
supprimer je pense à l'école Bizet qui
va être réhabiliter oui mais ça fait
trois ans qu'on en parle au début il y
avait simplement un partenariat public
privé ensuite on nous a expliqué qu'il
fallait la démolir et pour payer la
reconstruction vendre le terrain et
construire un immeuble maintenant on
nous dit ah non l'étude est bonne on
peut réhabiliter ça fait trois ans de
perdu ça fait de l'argent de perdu
puisque les études c'est quand même
payant et puis il y a des échecs les
échecs de la ZAC sont tous du monde ou
aujourd'hui elle est au point mort il
n'y a plus de Zac c'est passé sur un
projet privé c'est encore au point mort
aujourd'hui la ZAC renard qui a démarré
avec bien du retard et qui à mon avis
doit être repensé le maire n'arrive pas
bien à gérer tout ce qui est humain les
services sont
alors je vais pas dire maltraités c'est
un mot très fort mais il y a quand même
eu un cabinet qui a été chargé de
regarder un petit peu ce qui se passait
au niveau du personnel et la conclusion
c'était que les déchirures les querelles
intestines à cette majorité
rechillissait sur le personnel
il ne le gère pas puisqu'il en est déjà
son troisième directeur général des
services il ne gère pas davantage son
équipe puisque aujourd'hui on a ressenti
quand même assez fort de votre part pour
tout à fait pour dire on va on va monter
une liste aujourd'hui vous êtes dans un
groupe de position on l'a bien compris
que deux avec Fanny Braun et puis en
face de vous il y a un autre groupe de
position celui qui est mené par Étienne
et racimus qui alors je veux dire
récupérer mais le mot n'est pas très
beau mais en tout cas compte sur sa
liste des anciens colistiers de Bernard
de bain maintenant le groupe devient un
peu plus important est-ce qu'à un moment
donné vous n'avez pas eu envie de faire
alliance avec Ethan et racimus qui sera
candidat aussi aux municipal pour faire
une liste d'union pour tout dire il y a
plus d'un an et demi on avait commencé à
travailler ensemble et puis pour des
raisons différentes nous avons vu que
nous n'étions pas tout à fait sur le
même chemin donc on a cessé de
travailler ensemble maintenant le fait
comme vous dites qu'il est récupéré des
adultes
il a repris des adjointes de Monsieur
salle de bain moi je pense que à
quelques mois des élections c'est un
coup politique et comment peut-il avoir
de la crédibilité quand il attaque le
maire sur la suppression du foyer la
roche alors qu'il prend l'adjointe qui a
voté pour la suppression du lard du
foyer la roche comment peut-il être
crédible quand il critique la masse
salariale mais qu'il prend dans son
équipe l'adjointe qui était en charge du
personnel comment peut-il être crédible
quand il critique le bétonnage fait par
l'équipe en place alors qu'il prend
l'adjointe à l'urbanisme et je dirais
l'adjointe à l'urbanisme elle était
adjointe depuis 2001 donc ce n'est pas
très crédible c'est peut-être un bon
coup politique parce que ça affaiblit le
maire sortant mais pour moi c'est tout
sur quel thème vous allez mener campagne
alors vous avez parlé évoqué la
zacrenard mais bon ça y est la zacrenard
elle est lancée vous dites il faudrait
revoir des choses dessus mais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut revoir sur un projet qui est
aussi important le projet est lancé mais
c'est la première partie qui est lancée
cette ZAC renard devait en deux tranches
donc la première tranche est lancée
effectivement on voit des bulles de
vente donc ça c'est la première tranche
avec des logements un groupe scolaire
une crèche effectivement ça on ne peut
plus rien changer par contre la deuxième
tranche ne devrait être lancée que d'ici
2016 ou 2017 là il est encore temps dès
le 31 mars puisqu'on va prendre
l'hypothèse qu'il y ait deux tours quand
même dès le 31 mars on peut renégocier
avec l'aménageur et remettre des
équipements qui nous manquent par
exemple du logement intermédiaire
aujourd'hui on a deux sortes de
logements le logement HLM et le logement
un petit peu plus haut de gamme or
aujourd'hui dans les HLM il y a des gens
qui payent des surloyés et qui
voudraient bien partir mais ne peuvent
pas parce que les loyers dans le privé
sont trop chers donc il faut du logement
intermédiaire il faudrait aussi faire de
la des réserves foncières cet espace de
la ZAC renard c'est le dernier espace
dont dispose la ville pour faire quelque
chose pour le futur il faut bien voir
qu'on est en train de croître pour
atteindre 25 000 habitants dans quelques
années il y a pas de réserve il n'y aura
plus de réserve foncière dans Saint-Cyr
aujourd'hui on a un centre technique
municipal qui est coincé mais vraiment
dans des locaux très étroits qu'ils
n'ont pas de place faudrait peut-être
prévoir une réserve foncière pour en
faire un alors je dis pas dans cette
mandature parce que il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire mais pour l'avenir et
gouverner c'est prévoir jusqu'à ce que
plus ample informé donc revoir en tout
cas la deuxième phase de la zacrenard
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres priorités pour
la commune c'est pour la commune en fait
c'est le stationnement c'est ce que nous
disent tous les Saint-Cyriens sur tous
les commerçants alors c'est vrai que
notre situation n'est pas très facile on
est coin un petit peu entre une colline
une voie ferrée trois départementales
mais je pense que en regardant
précisément quartier par quartier on
peut très bien trouver des places de
stationnement supplémentaires sans
détruire les espaces verts parce que ça
nous les conserverons et ferons nous
ferons tout pour que ce soit conservé
quel regard vous vous portez sur sur la
campagne parce qu'il y a quand même pas
mal de candidatures là bon il y a celle
de Bernard de main le maire sortant il y
a celle des ténérés
à gauche il y a Daniel garçon et
Jean-Yves Maximilien vous avez pas peur
de déstabiliser tout ça va un peu
déstabiliser les électeurs écoutez
sincèrement non je ne le pense pas pour
moi le panorama actuel c'est il y a deux
listes de gauche deux listes de droite
moi je présente une liste indépendante
voilà parce que je pense que pour une
ville comme Saint-Cyr il est vraiment
pas nécessaire d'être affilié à un parti
ce serait des élections
style cantonales
j'ai été oui jusque 2010 et j'ai quitté
l'UMP volontairement parce que par des
tas de raisons et je trouvais que ça
n'apportait rien de particulier et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui ça n'apporte rien
de plus que ce soit un parti ou un autre
ça n'apporte rien de plus à une gestion
municipale donc vous ne sollicité aucune
investiture pour votre liste vraiment
sans étiquette tout à fait sans
étiquette et tous mes colistiers ils
tiennent beaucoup il est pas question de
leur dire que c'est une liste de droite
ou une liste de gauche ils y tiennent
énormément vous avez terminé votre liste
oui bien sûr elle est terminée mais elle
est pas figée encore vous savez s'il
faut faire une liste pour demain elle
est faite mais cette liste actuelle
n'est déjà plus la même que celle d'il y
a un mois et peut-être qu'elle évoluera
encore donc si
la porte est encore ouverte oui bien sûr
merci beaucoup Gaétanne des jardins
d'être venu sur le plateau municipal
2014 je rappelle vous êtes candidate
donc d'une liste indépendante sans
étiquette tout à fait voilà sur la ville
de Saint-Cyr-l'École les missions est
terminée merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous mardi 4 février l'émission
vous sera présentée par Wilfried Richie
bonne soirée